[موسيقى]
بعد اربعه واربعين عاما جمعت خلالها مكتبه
الساقيه عربا وكتابا ومثقفين من مختلف
انحاء العالم تغلق المكتبه نهايه ديسمبر
محلها الاكبر في اوروبا
بمحطه الثقافيه لم تعد قادره على اكمال
مشوارها بسبب اعباء بريطانيا الاقتصاديه
المتزايده
العرب
[موسيقى]
سياسيه في المنطقه العربيه والعالم وباتت
ملجا للعديدين للتعبير عن ارائهم او
احتجاجاتهم
ما في حدا يكسرنا قزايز المكتب يكسروا لنا
الواجهه لانه في كتاب معجبه او حديث يقول
لك ممنوع الموسيقى ليه حاكيني موسيقى
[موسيقى]
ويكاد لا يسمع احد خبر اغلاق المكتبه دون
شعوري بغصه خسارتي كنز ثقافيه القراءه
تتريك وسلوى مكتبه الساقيه على امل تسليم
شعلتها الثقافيه لجيل شاب يقدر ما انتجته
المكتبه من تجربه غنيه تشرف الثقافه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
الى هذه المكتبه مكتبه دار الساقي تغلق
ابوابها بعد اكثر من 40 عاما تطورت فيها
التكنولوجيا بسرعه فائقه جعلت من
المطبوعات الورقيه والمحافظه على شغفي بها
عبئا في ظل اوضاع اقتصاديه صعبه تمر بها
بريطانيا
عروب عبد الحق العربيه